okay ready here we go and start
[Music]
who would play you in the movie of your
life oh uh beast that's a uh that's a
tough one um
george clooney
what's your coffee order a coffee order
uh a triple grande vanilla latte
delicious with an extra shot of espresso
calm down no do we believe in ghosts
uh yeah
have you ever seen a ghost i did i had a
connection with one with i was with uh
the long island medium once really
what'd she like uh she was great and uh
we spoke to my uh grandmother constance
higgins wow in a haunted museum in
canada and it was quite uh interesting
experience because a lot of things were
said that there's no way the long island
medium could have possibly known so that
she knows it all right last question
what time did you go to bed last night
last night i went to bed at
11 o'clock what time do you wake up
seven
that's a good night's rest yeah it was
good i wanted to i wanted to be rested
for the show today a well-rested top
green
[Music]
you